hello leader it should be fine now sorry
there's a little bit of a delay but it
looks fine
no worries thank you okay good evening
everybody we will
make a start then with item one of
tonight's executive agenda
which is attendances and it's just to
note that apologies have been received
from councillor freeman
i'm not aware of any other apologies um
item two is questions from members of
the public and again i'm not aware that
any have been
received item three is declarations of
interest are there any declarations of
interest um on any of the items
on the agenda at all
yes leader if i could declare an
interest i'm not a decision maker but
uh i think it's probably proper to
declare an interest in item nine which
is the amalgamation
of stanford park infants and stuff apart
junior schools thank you very much
thanks councilman okay um
item leader sorry oh yeah sorry andy
uh just again similar to uh
um again to not quite sure if i need to
but i'll do it properly
um agenda item seven i work for um an
energy company which does supplier both
electricity and gas is one of its
uh roles thank you thanks councillor
morgan okay
so um item four then is
minutes um and it's to receive and if
members of the executive happy to do so
approve the minutes of the executive
meeting of the 27th of february can they
be
approved please
thank you item five is matters from
council or overview and scrutiny
committees
um i'm not aware of any business
no okay
um which moves us on to the first
substantive item on the agenda
item six places for everyone counsellor
right
please thank you leader uh
following stockport council deciding not
to vote in favor of the gmsf being
forwarded to the planning inspector
the other nine authorities within
greater manchester including trafford
still appreciate the undoubted
advantages of working collaborative
collaboratively
to secure economic and housing growth
but also to tackle the climate emergency
this report confirms the framework for
the setting up of places for everyone
and the governmentals governmental
structure
it is intended that if successful nine
out of the ten boroughs in greater
manchester will work together to devise
a joint plan that not only provides an
economic recovery
recovery from the pandemic but also
provides the homes that we need into the
future
as i'm sure the executive will be aware
based on the conservative government's
housing and population figures unless
trafford works collaboratively with the
other eight authorities within greater
manchester
we will lose the right to allocate green
belt for development
and likely be forced to allow
development of greenbelt which is
undesirable to our residents and
businesses
without a collaborative approach such as
places for everyone
on top of the already proposed greenbelt
release at timberlee wedge in carrington
we will be required to find further land
for up to five thousand more homes
on top of our current allocation this
would never
inevitably lead to further green belt
loss i move the report thank you leader
thank you council right sorry just
struggling to
get myself um organized with the tech
there um okay so are there any
questions or comments from members of
the executive at all
questions or comments more widely i've
got councillor myers
yes thank you uh thank you leader can i
ask councillor right if
based on what he's just said whether
there's an intention to revisit
the whole question of the greenbelt land
or are we just going to sort of
leave it as is at the moment thank you
that's the right as part of the as part
of the framework we will revisit the
uh the the various green belt released
and
an allocation of various sites across
the whole of greater manchester
however um as a council we still stand
by the fact that simply wedging
currencies are the most desirable parts
to for greenbelt release
but things potentially could change as
part of the plan
thank you councillor right councilman
blackburn
thank you leader could ask please um
will the council be promoting the
brownfield
sites first as a priority over and above
building on any greenfield sites
i don't need to bring you in on that
council all right we know the answer is
yes
councillor new gosh please
covered one of my points there how how
this
enforced that i was interested to know
but i will move on
and ask um the the options that were
given
in this that the options are this or
this
um i'm now just trying to find those
options um
but would be to just do a local plan and
move away well
that was the same ultimatum given to
stockport and yet
uh coming up to the vote significant um
and uh significant reductions in their
allocation were offered so
what is um what is the uh
chances that we can gain these
significant
reductions that stockport had when they
when they were voting on it
thank you that's all right well the
whole point in working
collaboratively is to uh is to negotiate
on these matters however um given the
fact that we have already
significantly reduced our green belt
take throughout the gmsf process
whether we can um take further uh
greenbelt land out of the allocation
um is yet to yet to be seen um it would
be desirable for us to be able to do so
but at the same time
we we have got a significant housing
shortage in a significant
housing crisis in this borough so
whether that will be possible we will
see through the um the period of time
that this
takes to to come through thank you
and councilman morgan
thank you leader um quick question for
councillor right um
obviously this is for nine boroughs um
we've gone down already from ten um and
we've already been doing talking about
this for a very long time you know i've
been accounts for two years now
and uh this has been spoken for very
much longer than i i was a counselor and
probably
a number of councils on here um so what
happens
if yet another council decides to fall
out of it
either after the local elections in may
or at a later stage
um kind of what sort of kind of
provisions has councillor wright and
all the other the council leaders um
built into this procedure
thank you that's the right do you want
to answer that
i think it's the million dollar question
to a certain degree counselor morgan
however
um we uh we have a significant desire to
work collaboratively with all the local
authorities
whether that would form um us going it
alone
on a local plan basis or whether that
would
form us going collaboratively with one
or two or three or the local authorities
is yet to be seen obviously we hope that
the places for everyone framework works
first
um but we we obviously do have to have
contingencies in place should it not
however i cannot emphasize enough that
if we don't work collaboratively with
other local authorities
then we will need to find land for
significantly more homes than we
currently do
thank you thanks councillor evans
thank you thank you leader and i've got
to say i was surprised that
following his death in stockport how
quickly not even
eight days later it was revived like a
frankenstein's monster of a plan
um but uh section 2.2 the very final
line
it will be it will be helpful i wouldn't
mind knowing
and i can do it as a freedom of
information request but it would be
helpful to save all that trouble
to know how much it has cost so far and
and i think it stretches back possibly
six maybe seven years
uh trafford and how much is likely to
cost
and perhaps over the next 18 months two
years
that could actually uh executive members
to find that out for me
and and then just as a final question
the five obviously it's political
the reductions that uh stockport secured
at the back end of their their
negotiations to try and get them on
board
was a political decision so there are 5
000
homes there that no doubt are up for
grabs
could i ask the executive member and
possibly probably the leader really
that they are did uh delivered equitably
rather than politically i would imagine
they'll probably go to bury it and
they'll probably come here
as vulnerable labor seats and
i would like that i'm putting this on
record now i can see that's what's going
to happen with
her and it would be good if it was done
equitably not politically
um councillor wright would you like to
come in first on the importance of this
not being handled politically
thank you lady yeah this this is
um this is not a political um framework
this is
a framework for the not the remaining
nine local authorities
to not just secure economic um
growth but also also to secure housing
growth and provide
the homes that uh the residents of the
greater manchester
conorbation require uh we are working
collaboratively because
uh what we don't with the situation we
don't want to be in is that trafford
becomes um
well trafford ends up with having to
allocate far more greenbelt to build the
homes that are required in this borough
um the fact that we are able to offset
some of that um
housing growth to other other parts of
greater manchester
is very beneficial particularly to
borrowers like trafford
um in relation to the um request
for um the the cost of the planner i can
certainly come back to you on that i'm
sure i can
get that information from officers i'm
but are happy to pass over to the
leadership should you wish to make a
comment
um further um i think i'll move through
the questions council all right um
[Music]
thanks for that uh councillor cobbins
please
thanks peter and yeah i want to take
issue first of all with the um
carbon reduction box and the
introductory materials where it says
that places for everyone will
uh include policies that seek to reduce
carbon
and now while there are some policies in
there to seek to do that we also know
it involves um increased airport use and
also crucially building on precious
wetlands like carrot and moss
and so these things are actually going
to increase our
our greenhouse gas emissions um building
on the mosque will
mean extracting the peace um which is
taking out a fossil fuel out of the
ground here in trafford
not in cumbria like we've seen in in in
the press recently
um and and releasing that very ancient
carbon into the environment
um and but also crucially mean that the
wetlands will be lost um
for posterity so the wetlands take in
carbon from the air
and they keep it unlike uh forests and
other
dry areas to take it in and release it
again as as plants rot
and so we're really losing um you know
for posterity that ability to sequester
carbon
so i really um i suppose wanted to hear
your take on
um on that point and whether we could
perhaps
excuse me perhaps be a bit more accurate
about it
and secondly um and cancer evans has
covered some of this with stockport
coming out there are those
5 000 units up for grabs so to speak
stockport like trafford was a net
beneficiary of the
um of the old gmsf and
so i suppose i had been hoping that when
that happened
i would see a lot of serious effort
behalf of trafford
to say actually can we save some more of
our green belt here
can we really focus on the sites of
special scientific interests can we
really focus on the wetlands
can we um i i um i know professor um
professor sorry councillor evans and
i've just
promoted you nathan um cancer heavens
mentioned um
doling those out equitably actually and
we believe in the green party
that these need to be dealt out on the
basis of minimizing our carbon impact
our land is is something that we won't
get back and
and this will be lost um in perpetuity
so is there anything we can do to secure
some of those stockport
um allocations um and save some of our
most precious spots
thanks that's the right you want to
cover off those two points around the
5000 and around the
carbon impact in the round thanks thank
you leader
just in relation to the comments you
made about carrington moss
um council the coggies to be aware that
we're currently out to consultation
um on that particular point as we speak
uh so it wouldn't be in relation to the
road i should say
which is the main part of the greenbelt
release that would encourage a mosque
that
we would lose um so i wouldn't
necessarily be able to comment on that
at this stage
however um in the labour party what i
would suggest is that
um we are absolutely focused on tackling
the homelessness
crisis that we have in greater
manchester and the housing crisis that
we have in trafford
um and um as far as i'm concerned the
most important thing that we can do
at this moment in time is provide the uh
the housing that is
absolutely required for the people that
not just live in the borough that but
also want to remain in the borough who
can't afford to either rent or buy
in the um in the in the borough at this
stage thank you
may i maybe just right i'm not sure the
bringing out consultation on
the road um stops uh commenting on
issues like the airport
and the general principle that uh it
seems like that line isn't
isn't quite accurate and but also i just
want to take a issue with the
short-termism and the um small-minded
view we have here
this is about a long-term impact on a
global scale
and what's happened over decades is
everyone everywhere has made short-term
decisions about the problem we have
right here right now
and this is yes this is about housing
but this is about the long-term impact
on a huge number of people's housing
around the world not just
short-term impact here in trafford
thanks um
councillor right with your permission
i'll take that because it requires a
um an environmental and sustainability
response in the round but i do have to
say
um there is nothing more short-termist
than refusing to tackle our housing
crisis
in my view um and that was the point
that council the right was making it is
absolutely imperative that the area
that we represent in trafford this
administration is doing everything it
can to tackle the housing crisis and
this is a fundamental part of that
council the right was referring to his
ability to
comment on carrington moss in particular
when he articulated the
difficulties that he would have in
responding to the issues because of the
consultation on the relief road but when
it comes to environmental concerns more
generally
you're absolutely right councillor
coggins and we would never suggest that
there isn't a tension
between providing the homes that people
need and the
issues that we face environmentally or
indeed economic growth versus the issues
that we face environmentally
and so we can bring the airport and
other drivers of economic growth into
the mix as well but there is um unlike
the sites that are being discussed here
which as far as i'm aware are not
um definitively in the places for
everyone's strategy at this point
although clearly it would be somewhat
naive for me to
expect you to believe that you're
unaware of the sites that may come
forward
but let's discuss one of the things that
really is in that document which is
a commitment to zero carbon homes in
greater manchester
which is a commitment to better
transport connectivity which are things
that will
lead to positive changes for our
environment and so we do have to look at
these things
in the round there are positives and
negatives
but the biggest driver behind this from
this
from this labor administration's
perspective and the biggest priority
is tackling that housing crisis in
trafford and i do not believe that you
can do that
given the numbers imposed upon us by
government and given the scale of the
homelessness and donor and in
affordability crisis
unaffordability crisis that we have in
trafford
without encroaching on the green belt as
things currently stand clearly that will
be kept under review clearly we hope
that the conservative government might
take some steps to recognize
um that that is the case but in the
meantime we are where we are we will
continue
to attempt to drive down the numbers
that are required of us here in trafford
but i have to say
that what is being missed here by all
speakers so far from other parties
and particularly councillor evans is the
is the quite
astonishing job that has been done by
this administration in reducing
the um initial number of homes planned
for trafford's green belt because
obviously
there has been a reduction of several
thousand since
um the conservatives lost control of
trafford
and we will continue as we always have
done
and as we have a record of doing of
striving to protect our green belt
and actually you know when councilor
evans talks about
politically close councils um as
a leader of another of an opposition
with 19 seats out of 63 he should
remember that the biggest threat to the
green belt in trafford
is the conservative party it is their
government's targets
upon which we are acting it is their
administration
that selected crossfit bridge for the
potential
homing of a rugby stadium and more on
that later
on the agenda it is that administration
that selected turn moss
for a private football club to build all
over and of course
not in labor's plans even if we have to
go ahead
and unchange from where we were on
previous iterations
are not just several thousand homes at
carrington and simply wedge but 750
homes
at flixton so we have made strides we
understand the importance of this we
know the environmental impact but we
will continue
to look at that in the round driven by
our overarching ambition as a labour
administration to tackle
the housing crisis we cannot do that
without being part of places for
everyone unless we give up
far more of our green belt and i think
you accept that in fairness councillor
copkins you've always accepted
that the best way for us to drive those
numbers down
is to work together is to lean on
neighboring boroughs such as manchester
and salford and that is what we will do
to continue to attempt to secure as
little green belt releasing traffic as
is possible
and i have to say without slapping
ourselves on the back the numbers speak
for themselves
there's always more to do and it will
never ever be perfect there will always
be people who are against it
but there has been superb progress made
in that regard over the last three years
and with that i can see councillor new
gosh wants to come back in
just briefly um i mean i haven't seen
places for everyone
in detail yet but gmsf did not include
just houses there was 4.2 million square
feet of industrial
and 2.4 million square feet of new
office space um some of which is
proposed for timply wedge 60 000 square
meters um
and using 2.2 here you're using
utilizing the same evidence base
pre-covered how is it that we are going
to get the right answers for our future
if you're not even going to acknowledge
the the major thing that's occurred in
our country's
current um for the future plans
that's the right do you want to comment
on the economic impact
yeah i mean i think it's i mean clearly
the the
the pandemic's going to form part of
places for everyone framework i mean it
is worth noting
um as part of this that this is this is
simply a technical report
i'm setting up the structures to process
the plan we are we've got a lot of work
to do as part of the plan
um and um there is going to be a lot of
work amongst the nine local authorities
over the coming weeks and months
to discuss through all of this
information this report is simply a
technical report to provide the
structures
um as we go forward so it's work
this debate is obviously very worthwhile
but i think it'd be better had frankly
uh when we've got more detail in the uh
in the plan going forward
thank you
councillor writer is as you say um
presumptuous although i do accept
um that it would not take a genius to to
make some assumptions around the
direction of travel to say
definitively what will be in the points
about whether or not we will be able to
reduce the numbers further or well made
we will continue as we always have to
see if that is possible
um i don't appreciate the suggestion
that this will be done politically and
certainly as i said to councillor evans
given the site of the conservative group
in trafford
i don't think that we would be at the
top of the queue alongside berry
um but perhaps he's um hoping for rather
better election results in may than
logic would dictate as possible um i
would just remind him given some of his
social media today when he accuses this
labour administration and colleagues
across greater manchester of hypocrisy
there is nothing more hypocritical than
the approach that trafford conservatives
have taken
on the greater manchester spatial
framework and now
on places for everyone because three
four five years ago they were banging on
about the need to work together to
protect green belt in trafford
having done a pathetic job of doing so
with thousands more units on the green
belt
than we have now proposed to take in the
gmsf
and may or may not come forward three
places for everyone and i just
want to say this it is
fact that when the conservatives were in
office in trafford they claimed that the
labor group
were a threat to our green belt because
we opposed 750
and then just 375
of the conservatives proposed units on
greenbelt
in trafford we always said reluctantly
that we accepted the case for greenbelt
bill to meet
the conservative government's housing
targets
and that therefore we would support
carrington and simply wedge
here we have a conservative group who
rejects all of that
and says that we should be going on our
own 5
000 more units on our green belt
than would be the case by working
collaboratively and that
5 000 may come down um in terms that may
indeed go up if we are to secure any
further
um support from other boroughs but i
just find the hypocrisy of it incredible
to call
this administration hypocritical when
you i'm just going to read
a motion that you supported in 2017
councillor evans an amendment to a
motion
council recognizes the unaffordability
of housing in trafford is a crisis that
cannot
continue to be ignored and will require
decisive action
to resolve the council is concerned that
the labour party
remember supporting all but by this
point 375
of the homes allocated in trafford
all but 375 but you were concerned
that the labour party has not set out
how it would meet
the housing challenge which puts at risk
all land across the borough to
future uncontrolled development
hypocritical
councillor evans you don't know the
meaning of the word if you cannot
see the irony in what you are saying
doing and tweeting you and your group
are an embarrassment on this our
residents know it and to come on here
and describe trafford as politically
dicey for the labour party
when this is the best you can come up
with bring it
on now i think the
um debate has been had on this issue
we've heard from everybody who wanted to
come in and so if i could ask um members
of the executive if they are happy
to approve the recommendations as set
out in the report
thank you okay so if we move to
the next item on the agenda which is the
procurement of gas and water supplies
counselor right please thank you leader
uh this report asks the executive to
approve the signing of a new contract
with corona energy unfortunate name for
the times
for the supply of gas and wave water
business limited for the supply of water
to the council's buildings further
details can be found in the report
however this is just to reiterate
something already mentioned within the
report
that the council recognizes it cannot
continue to rely on the supply of gas
for heating and lighting its buildings
and as per the report that went to
executive last month the operation the
state strategy
the council as part of our commitment to
zero carbon and dealing with the climate
emergency will be actively
seeking new forms of energy going
forward
thank you leader thank you councillor is
there any questions or comments from
members of the executive
no questions or comments more why the
counselor cop ins
sorry sorry it's a legacy handle okay no
problem
um councillor morgan please
thank you leader um counselor can i just
ask is this
because i too honestly i got completely
confused about reading this report is
this a variable or fixed
contract because it uses both in the
same sentence
and i've got a follow-up question after
that it depends what your answer is
i'm going to come to register for legal
clarity
richard or jane
uh i believe it's uh variable
thank you okay okay to honestly that
that doesn't cause i thought it was
fixed um i just kind of put on record um
if it the reason i asked was that uh
energy
gas prices are um a uh three-year high
so just checking that on that that we
are entering into a fixed contract
and given a cold spell that northeast
asia has just had
thank you
thank you um not seeing any other hands
on this so with that um the
recommendations are
set out um on the covering page of the
report
can the executive approve those please
thank you um item eight is crossover
bridge fields and trust dedication
councilor wright again please
thank you leader i am delighted to bring
this report which seeks approval from
the executive to protect crossroad
bridge playing fields in sale via
fielding trust deed of dedication
following the consultation that took
place in 2020 and the feedback received
from residents
the council believes this is the most
sensible approach to protecting this
valuable green space
which is appreciated by the local
community once the full application is
made to the fields in trust
this will provide reassurance that this
site will remain a publicly
accessible green space for the various
forms of recreation that currently
take place i ask that the executive
approves the report
thank you leader thank you
um counselor wright are there any
questions or comments from
members of the executive at all can i
just come in please leader oh you would
yeah go ahead thank you um
just very briefly um just to welcome
this really positive step i think it's
another example of this administration's
commitment to our
open spaces um alongside this
designation we
have ambitions to enter into a long-term
lease with crossfit
bridge management association which will
offer them long-term
long-term security and then and enable
them to develop their facilities
i hope that this should offer
reassurance to the clubs and the
community about our commitment
to the future development of our outdoor
sports provision in the borough
thank you thanks councillor patel um
just opening this up more widely then
i've got councillor
please uh thank you very much uh lead uh
and
uh thank you uh councillor patel for
your comments
and uh we would be supportive also of of
that the question i had was about
um uh you know the various sort of
conditions if you like that
we enter into with uh fields in trust
presumably uh those conditions which are
quite
you know restrictive they lapse
presumably at the expiration
of the lease period do they
and and and presumably we're talking
about you know quite a
quite a long lease period of some 25
years possibly i would i would guess
so so the main question is about you
know uh on the expiration of the lease
do those do those conditions lapse i i
guess so but it's not made clear in the
report
thank you very much thank you um i'm
suspecting
that that may well be one for richard or
jane
um but but i do think it's it's um
it's a particular one with specific
regards to the lease
richard yeah i can take that uh no it
doesn't lapse they're
they're separate uh matters so the least
is
25 years that's in accordance with our
long-term security of 10-year
programme and that's with crossford
bridge management association
the field in trust is a permanent
medication so it doesn't lapse this time
there's no time limit on that
thank you are you happy with that john
yeah no the answer's clear enough yeah
no thank you thank you
thanks um okay not seeing anybody else
on this just to um welcome this
um personally this is a really positive
piece of news um i should declare that
it is in my ward in priory
i know that the sports clubs are really
keen to work with residents moving
forward to
enable the site to continue to be a hub
for grassroots sport
locally and i know that uh council patel
councillor wright councillor i've said
all of those with my um very muddled
briefs
um that i have are looking forward to
working with them
too so so really welcome um this news as
uh further commitment and proof of our
commitment to
um green spaces in trafford and
the um recommendations for us set out in
the report can they be agreed please
all right thank you item nine
is um the amalgamation of staff park
infants and junior schools um and that's
through the proposal to close stanford
park
infants and simultaneously expand the
juniors i'm going to come to
council hines on this but i um obviously
expecting that councilor carter may wish
to
um comment also thank you
leader um so uh as you already have
said and the proposal um tonight is for
the amalgamation of
stanford park junior school in infant
school um and it follows
the consultation with the governing
bodies of the schools
with parents staff and other
stakeholders
um as you've said the proposal is to
close doctor park infant school
and expand the age range of the junior
school so that it forms a single primary
school
and this is being proposed um because
from january 21
um there's a vacancy in the headship of
stanford park
infant school and so this is in line
with the council's long-standing
presumption
to amalgamate policy um which does apply
in these circumstances
um unless there is a contra indication
such as the size or location of the
schools which there isn't
um in this case um so members may recall
that in january
the council published a statutory notice
um
regarding the proposed amalgamation and
announced a four-week
consultation and a representation
period and this was the final stage in
the consultation process um and it
followed
a six-week informal consultation um
that actually began on november the 9th
in
2020 and so 18 responses were received
in the formal consultation
stage and 12 of which were
very supportive of the proposal although
four of those
did express some concern uh regarding
the proposed implementation date um
the remaining six respondents didn't
state their specific support
of or objection to the amalgamation but
did restate
concerns that were expressed in the
earlier stages of the consultation
process
about the governance arrangements the
state of the buildings and their
disappointment that the provision of the
new school wasn't included
in the proposal the comments received
and the responses provided
are detailed in annex one
and the proposal um to the executive
this evening
doesn't include any expansion project
refurbishment um or new school
building um but there is a separate
ongoing
kind of work to consider site options
involving a range of partners um
so the proposal this evening is to
amalgamate schools
with a revised implementation date of
the 1st
of september 2020 and it's in
recognition really of the comments
that have been made um and it's a common
sense measure really
um given that schools face it you know
are facing incredible
challenges having only just uh fully
returned
um very recently and needing to rightly
focus on supporting children back into
school
and so the amalgamation of the schools
would enable the development of a single
vision for the school
and providing continuity of leadership
and
consolidate more effectively the high
quality education
that exists delivering advantages and to
staff
children and families and would also
enable a better continuity progression
of children's learning
and particularly between a key stage 1
and key
stage 2 and remove the requirement for
children
to transfer between um the schools at
the end of
year two and so i asked the executive
to consider the recommendations that are
on page
one report thank you leader thanks
councillor heinz i'm going to come
directly to councillor carter just to
see if there's anything that she wants
to add
no i'm fine thank you uh leader um
councillor heinz has covered everything
i think but i'm happy to answer
questions
thank you okay are there any questions
or comments from members of the
executive
no okay um i've got uh council evans
council coggins and councillor young as
it's her award i'm going to bring um
council mr young first but
thank you for letting me sleep later
i was quite happy when i read
this proposal i think the amalgamation
of the two schools
is actually a very good idea and from
talking to people around i think
generally speaking
the residents around are quite happy
with the amalgamation taking place it
was wanted
and i do agree with you counselor hines
that it was
a common sensical thing to do to move
the starting date to the first of
september
because it is i mean the children have
been messed about
as we all know so badly and they do need
to settle down
there's going to be an awful lot of
problems getting the two
buildings together really what i wanted
to ask was
can you assure me that you're making
every effort you could possibly make
to try and solve the problem of i don't
know whether we can have a new school
now
or whether because the amalgamation has
taken place
the possibility of a new build or
extensive build
isn't going to be there anymore but i
would appreciate being kept
very much up to date if there is any
chance
or any hope for a new school
in stamford park or instead of this
stanford park school
because the actual building as we all
know i think everybody will agree with
that who's seen it
it isn't really fit for purpose anymore
and i get quite sorry for the way the
children are crammed into that building
so um i i don't know whether there is
any anything you can give me as to what
the future
might hold i don't know whether because
of the
very sad the
[Music]
grade two listed status of this building
has now had
whether that means that it's absolutely
impossible
to build on or to alter the building in
any way
but it certainly isn't going to be very
comfortable for the children especially
because they're so crammed in there all
the time now
anyway thank you for listening to me
thank you
council mrs young i think i think some
good points in there i'll come to
councillor carter for a response
yes uh councillor young yeah absolutely
right to be honest and as you know we
did get money
it's expansion funding to increase the
number of places
at the school and so obviously the
original plan was to build a new
a new school we've got about eight
million pounds which would have got
gotten us a decent building
unfortunately because of the listing it
just means that we cannot bring in a
building
in the envelope now um and i know i mean
richard might want to say something he's
got a team looking at it with heritage
experts
i'm we're told there's a plan in the
pipeline
which um we have uh councillor hanson
myself haven't seen yet
but we have every empathy with you um
and at the moment our hands are a bit
tied
but obviously we will keep you in the
loop you know as soon as we've got
information we will be including the
award counsellors
okay thank you
sorry about that all sorts of issues um
counselor coggins please
thank you yeah i'm also welcome the
revised consultation today so that makes
a lot more sense
um i just had a quick concern about the
number of console t's
am i acknowledge cancer hines comments
about this being the end of a longer
consultation process
it does seem 18 is quite a small amount
and on the one hand i thought well maybe
this is a sign that actually all the
issues have been discussed and people
are quite happy with it
but having read the comments they
actually did seem to be really
quite strong feelings about this so um i
suppose the the small number
seems to contrast with this small
feeling are we with the strong feelings
are we really sure that we have done
everything we can to consult on this um
whilst also wanting to you know
acknowledge and appreciate the
difficulty that
officers and school staff must have had
um you know consulting
in these circumstances
councillor heinz or cancer carter who
would like that
i don't know we might both like that one
so
i mean i think it probably is reflective
of the fact that it's
it's come at the end of that um
informal consultation and a lot
of discussion that took place before
that there were
meetings of residence groups and they
were looking at the um
the school uh buildings there was
meetings for parents
when we were able to do that because it
was pre um covered
and i think it possibly is indicative of
the fact that people are
quite supportive of the amalgamation but
were seeking
um really some were seeking a new
building
others were very opposed to the new
building um
and it was it was quite a tense
situation but in terms of the
amalgamation
um i don't think there was much
opposition to the school's amalgamating
but their work concerns that obviously
have been highlighted as you quite
rightly say
in the report i must admit i was
surprised by
the number because i thought i knew that
there had been
um a lot of opinion that had been
expressed previously and was expecting
to see more but i do know that
um the consultation period was announced
through various forums and people the
school themselves were contacting
parents to let them know that it was
ongoing
um and we announced it on all our usual
channels and through um the press as
well so
i was surprised to see that there
weren't more but i think it probably is
indicative of the fact that the
conversation's been
ongoing for quite quite some time really
great yeah yeah it's exactly that
they've been consulted
um really okay no worries i'll bring
councillor evans in them please thank
you thank you leader can i thank
councillor young for her work
on the ground over the past probably two
years on this and
and fundamentally i echo all her
comments but one
on nominally unsettling thing i don't
know if the executive could bring
some uh influence on it
so it's my understanding that uh the
junior school governors are effectively
uh going to be running the whole thing
which is understandable
and is part of the arrangement it might
be uh
helpful if some of the infant school
governors
could in some way be drawn into the
governing body
my understanding is some are feeling
locked out and it feels more like a
takeover rather than a merger
that's more of a anecdotal comment but
it would be helpful i think if
er counselor carter perhaps worked on
that in some way
thank you absolutely councillor evans
and it did actually come up in the
consultation people mentioned about the
governance
um so i've already been talking to the
directors about
um you know what it you know what the
board might look like going forward
really because
absolutely you know we call this a
presumption to amalgamate we don't call
it a presumption to take over
and so you know sort of i think the
infant governors
do very very much need to have a voice
um
so we're working around how that might
happen
um going forward so you are right
councillor evans
thank you and new other speakers on this
item so the recommendations are us set
out from the report are the executive
happy to
approve those hi thank you
okay so item 10 is the section 75
partnership agreement on mental health
um councillor harving please thank you
leader um
i bring this report this evening for the
executive
to approve the proposal that we um
enter into an amended section 75
agreement with gmh
we have an existing section 75 agreement
which is
really quite out of date and it's not um
does not bring in current legislation of
the care act really
um as trafford are also on a journey to
transform our mental health strategy too
it seems really timely that we
update our very outdated section 75
agreement it's a legal framework
looking at how we collaborate with
partners across mental health
um so really um it details everything in
the report but i'm bringing it really to
seek the approval of the executive as
we're in pre-election period we don't
want any delays
to proceed with the section 75. thank
you leader
thank you council harbing any questions
or comments from members of the exact
questions or comments more why the
counselor coggins is that a new hand
sorry i really have to get in the habit
of taking my hand don't worry
no problem counselor smackdown thank you
leader
and i'm pleased to see this report which
is obviously
needed and i just wanted uh just to
get clarification uh section 18
uh it states that there will be a
quarterly report to the health and
wellbeing board
which you know obviously is is needed
and
in section 19 uh can you just confirm
that the arrangement is for a 10-year
duration and in section 20
there's a six months notice if the
agreement
by either parties is terminated could
you just sort of um
confirm that please thanks
councillor blackburn i'll bring in um
diane in a second just to
to outline some of the um to respond to
some of the questions you
you raise but you say it's needed i mean
like i said we do have an existing
um section 75 agreement with the mental
health trust so it's something that we
have
had in place i think one of our concerns
are that really
social work in mental health probably
isn't as recognized as it should be and
we need to make sure that we do bring
social work into mental health so yes in
regular updates as we transform our
mental health strategy
but i'll just bring in diane to to speak
to the contractual
side of things thanks diane thank you
councillor hardly and thank you
councillor blackburn for your interest
and the current agreement has been in
in place for a 10-year period and we
have a lot of
um changes in in play with the white
paper that's been issued and some of the
changes around nhs funding and ccg
changing in the next year so we want to
make sure this new agreement will carry
us through that process
so that we can ensure that the right
services are in place
i haven't agreed a 10-year period for
the renewal
and but i would want to make it at least
a three to five year period so that we
have that
assurance of joint working through these
changes so thank you councillor bachmann
okay thank you thank you diane thank you
all
um okay so the not seeing anybody else
to come in on this so the
recommendations are
set out in the report can they be
approved please
bye hi
that's a bit more enthusiastic thank you
um okay
that brings us on then to um the period
10 revenue budget monitor for 2021
and council ross please thank you leader
we are now forecasting an underspend of
2.3 million
which is a positive movement of 193 000
since period 8
and any underspend that we achieve
through the course of this year will be
placed in our budget support reserve
to support future budget decisions um
it's um
certain that covered costs will have a
long-term effect on our finances and the
recent budget also suggests
spending cuts for non-protected
government departments
which sadly include mhclg
so our prudent approach remains
necessary
the gross covert 19 pressures for the
year are now at 56.785 million which is
up 5.73 million on period 8
but we do have some positive views on
the improved council tax collection rate
so that should help us with future year
budget decisions so i'm just asking the
executive to
note our period 10 position
thank you councillor any questions or
comments from members of the executive
no positive movement is always welcome
um
questions or comments more widely
no okay um so the
report is for noting um as per the
recommendations
can they be approved please hi
great thank you item 12 is urgent
business
of which there is none um and the
exclusion resolution item 13 is not
required so that brings us to
the end of the meeting um thank you very
much
uh to everybody for your attendance i
will see you all at full council on
wednesday
thanks very much cheers